بيان لحزب الله واضح
ومقتضبة الكرام ولمشاهده الجزيره حقيقه
وجود الشهيد القائد صالح
العاروري في قلب الضاحيه الجنوبيه لسنوات
مضى كان يثقل على العدو الاسرائيلي هذا
الوجود لا بل ان كثر من الدبلوماسيين
والسفراء الاجانب المقيمين في بيروت كانوا
يتحدثون دائما عن وجود قاده المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في قلب الضاحيه وكانوا احيانا
يحددون صالح العاروري بالاسم هذا دليل ست
سلمى اي موقع مقاوم كان يمثله الرجل اي
حضور حيوي في اطار معركه المقاومه الكبرى
على مستوى ساحه محور المقاومه كان الشيخ
صالح يؤديه بقوه لذلك البيان الاولي الذي
صدر مساء اليوم عن حزب الله والذي يوصف
الامر بالجريمه التي لن تمر دون عقاب
واليد على الزناد وفي عباره رابعه ست سلمى
انه ما قبل هذا اليوم ليس كما بعده جراه
العدو بعمليه التنفيذ التي حصلت اليوم
والتي فيها كسر واضح لقواعد الاشتباك التي
كانت قائمه لسنوات مضت والتي اصلا تبلورت
بالنيران وبموازاة
ضربه اليوم هي تجاوز حقيقي لهذا الواقع
وهي فعل اقدام قام به العدو لكن النقاش
الحقيقي الست سلمى بظل هذا البيان الاولي
وظل التاكيد ان هناك مس جوهري واستراتيجي
بقواعد الاشتباك لكن تفصيل الكلام على ضوء
التقييم الذي يجري سياتي باطلاله سماحه
السيد حسن نصر الله عصر امس الاربعاء
السادس مساء واللي برايي انا ستكون مترافق
بتقييم اولي لدى المقاومه عن حقيقه ما جرى
خاصه ان الخرق الاساسي في العمليه التي
نفذت كان مرتبط
بالاجتماع الذي كان يعقد في هذا المكان
باطار عمل
المقاومه المتكامل على الارض ويبدو ان
النفاذ قد جم
من خلال هذا الاجتماع